>>From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>>It's my pleasure today to
introduce author, Thomas Mallon.
He has written 14 books and
he has both an international
and national audience but I'm
happy to say he is a local writer.
He lives in Washington and I was
told just before I came up here
that he is working on a
novel about Watergate.
His previous novels include
Henry and Clara, Two Moons,
and Dewey Defeats
Truman among others.
They have been renowned especially
those with historical settings
for the detail, and the
research, and the nuance
with which they depict times
removed from the present.
Thomas has also punched his
bureaucratic ticket in Washington.
He worked for the NEH and served
as the deputy chairman of the NEH
and he is the recently
appointed director
of the Creative Writing Program
at George Washington University.
He occasionally dabbles
in journalism and some
of you remember a recent
New Yorker article
in which he had the temerity
to question the reflexive respect
that's paid to an obscure novel know
as TO Kill a Mockingbird.
He called it "moral Ritalin" I
think, a phrase that I rather like.
His most recent book is Yours
Ever: People and Their Letters.
And so here to tell you
about it is Thomas Mallon.
[ Applause ]
>>Thomas Mallon: Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming.
It's nice to be here again.
I remember being here the
first time back in 2001,
with my fiction hat
on I think that year.
This time I've got
nonfiction hat on.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about this book about letters
that I've written called
Yours Ever.
When I was out doing the things
one does promoting a book,
one radio interviewer asked me a
really good question about how --
if there was a fire in your house
and, you know, you could go in
and you save one thing,
what would save,
the photographs or the letters?
And it's kind of an impossible
question but I remember saying,
I was thinking particularly about my
parents, both of them are gone now.
And I thought the letters because
I would remember what they looked
but the letters are so evocative
of their personalities,
their handwriting.
They both had kind of sad,
long, protracted, declines
and it's visible in the way
they would write letters.
And, you know, the ones that they
sent me when I was a freshman
in college I still have them
with the six cents stamp
with Franklin Roosevelt on it and
they're evocative of the whole time.
And so I wanted to write
this book about a genre
that there's no getting
around it is dying out.
Letters are becoming a
kind of specialty genre.
We reserve them now for special
occasions like sympathy letters.
Most of us still think it's kind
of tacky to send a sympathy e-mail,
you know, or a sympathy text
I think would be rock bottom
in terms of the human spirit.
But the everydayness
of letters which is
to a great extent being
replaced by e-mail and so forth
which we're not really saving
despite our ability to archive it.
We're not really holding
onto it all that much.
This is something that we're
losing something we need
to really I think cope with.
And I tried to make this
book, which explores some
of the great letter
writing of all time.
It's not an anthology.
As one person said, its anthology
told in the anthologist own words.
There is a lot of quotation
from letters but it's a kind
of running commentary on collections
of letters that intrigue me,
excited me, that I
liked, that annoyed me.
It's very whimsical.
It doesn't try to be
encyclopedic and inclusive.
It tries to suggest the whole
terrain that's out there
without actually being
absolutely comprehensive.
I started this book in 1994.
It was 13 years overdue
at the publisher
by the time I handed it in.
When I started writing
it a stamp cost 29 cents.
I did not have an e-mail account.
No one had any idea what texting
is or what Twittering might be.
I still have half an idea of it.
Somebody recently told me that
emailing is for old people.
Somebody who lives her entire life
texting now and I generally bring
up the rear where technology
is concerned.
I'm not a guide to the future.
So I thought maybe I could have some
usefulness as a guide to the past.
But when I started writing the book,
I really didn't know that we were
on the verge of this
enormous sea change.
And the book was always intended
to be companion volume to a book
about diaries that I had
written 25 years ago.
Same kind of approach,
opinionated, old fashion, whimsical,
what interested me, what I
hoped might interest readers.
And I thought I wanted to
suggest the same kind of landscape
about letter writing without
being kind of a scold.
I mean the book is unquestionably
or implicitly nostalgic.
I mean I do think we're on
the verge of losing something
with the disappearance of the letter
as an everyday form of activity.
But, you know, I didn't
want to be hectoring
and I'm entering my kind of, you
know, Andy Rooney years anyway.
I doubt miss this.
Whenever -- I mean I
didn't want to do that.
I eventually embraced
all of the technology.
I e-mail, I text, I do not Twitter.
>>Thomas Mallon: But,
you know, I'm with it.
Although I still think that the --
to me the absolute
perfect thing was the fax.
To me it was the sweet spot.
It had a very brief life, the
fax but it combined the best
of both worlds; it
was fast, efficient.
Jessica Mitford, the great English
writer who got used to faxing
at the very end of her life
when she was in her 80s,
she adapted all these letter
conventions to the fax.
She would fax her sister back and
write yours of 9:54 p.m., received.
And you had something to hold onto.
And it just seemed to me my
preferred stopping point.
But the fax had really
a very brief life.
I think it was in the saddle
as a mode of communication
for probably five years before
everybody turned to e-mail.
This book is organized around
the motives people have
for writing letters.
Why they actually write them.
The chief reason has
always been absence
and the letter is a
bridge over distances.
You couldn't travel to
somebody you were separated
from so there's a chapter
about such things.
Friendship, the way in which
there are certain friendships
that really exist not
on paper alongside
in person, but exist only on paper.
One of them, my favorite ones is
the friendship between George Sand,
the French kind of bestselling
writer of the 19th century,
and Flaubert, the artistic
agonizer squeezing out the [
indiscernible], torturing
himself over every word.
And George Sand says, oh, you know,
my proofs of novel came today.
I usually don't bother with them.
I don't bother reading them.
And, you know, Flaubert is
neurotic about everything.
I think and yet she
understood his neuroses and she
to him was this kind
of earth mother figure.
I think if they saw one
another in person all the time,
they would've driven one
another absolutely crazy
and yet it worked on paper.
It was the right medium for that.
And it think you may
have experienced
that in your own letter writing.
I'm sure that you e-mail
with certain people
and much prefer e-mailing
with them than being
on the telephone with them.
And I think we -- relationships
adapt
to whatever medium
we carry them out in.
There's a chapter on advice,
letters particularly --
letters from parents to children
who frequently been full of advice.
There's a whole collection
of Scott Fitzgerald's letters
to his daughter Scotty when she
was a young woman and Vassar.
And his advice is very particular.
But one day when he's in
a more generalizing mood,
he says to herself, just do
everything completely differently
from what your mother and I did
and you should be all right.
>>Thomas Mallon: There's
a chapter on complaint.
Sometimes letters used for
serious reformist complaint.
Florence Nightingale when
she arrives in the Crimea
and is horrified by the hospital
conditions sends back these
scathing, vivid letters to the
war office in England that lead
to a complete revolution in
the way medicine is practiced
on the battlefield.
And the fact that she could sustain
these complaints day after day
and letter after letter had an
enormous effect on the world.
That chapter includes that
it's outer stream, hate mail
and goes all the way
up to the Unabomber.
Needless to say, there are
love letters in the book.
The correspondence
between George Bernard Shaw
and Mrs. Patrick Campbell, the
actress, a chased correspondence
but they had a kind of flirtation
without any physicality to it.
They refer to themselves as
lusty lions at one point.
And eventually when she's
down on her luck financially,
she wants to sell his
letters to make some money.
He resists and tries to explain
to her that there's a difference
between physical property, the
ownership of the actual paper letter
and intellectual property,
his words.
You can't quote them
without violating copyright.
She never can grasp this distinction
no matter how many times he explains
it to her and she finally with
hurt feelings says Dear Joey,
which she called him
for unusual reasons,
my letters are worth two cents,
yours 50 quid so bother to answer.
And she gave up on the idea.
The worst set of love letters
of all time, the love letters
between the Duke and
Duchess of Windsor.
Sickening.
I mean yes we all say things in love
that we don't say in other context.
We, yes, we talk baby talk
even on paper sometimes.
But to listen to the man who was
supposed to be King of England go on
and in this infantile
manner letter after letter,
after letter is kind of sick making.
And they always sign themselves
"we" because it blended Wallace,
Wallace Simpson and Edward
the Eighth and they --
each time they put it down, they
act as if it's the quaint age
of all time and are amazed by it.
There's confessions.
A whole chapter devoted to people
who write letters to say things
that they can't say or won't say to
their nearest and dearest in person.
Lady Melbourne who was on
of Byron's acquaintances.
She was the mother-in-law to his
onetime mistress, Caroline Lamb,
the woman who famously
said that Byron was mad,
bad and dangerous to know.
Her mother-in-law, Lady
Melbourne remained his confidant
after the affair and when he
disastrously married Annabella
Milbanke, he wrote to Lady
Melbourne, I got a wife and a cold
on the same day but have got
rid of the last pretty speedily.
And other chapters
on prison and war.
I think the greatest war
letters of all time are the ones
that Wilfred Owen, the poet,
sent home from the front.
Owen, nobody's idea of a soldier,
although he became quite a good one
but was the most kind of
delicate, sensitive personality,
the last boy you would imagine
being sent to the front.
There is no more vivid
documentary of the First World War
than the letters that Owen
sent home to his mother.
One of the things that
he was in charge
of as a company officer was taking
care of the mail and making sure
that it got distributed
to the soldiers
when it arrived at the front.
And one of this duties
was when that soldier
to whom the letter was addressed was
dead, to get the letter returned.
And he writes to his mother
late in the war when he,
this very sensitive fellow has
become hardened to everything.
He says I now don't even take
the cigarette out of my mouth
when I write deceased
over the envelope.
>>Thomas Mallon: It's
a shattering picture
of what war is actually
like day-to-day.
And I thought I would say since
we're in Washington, there are a lot
of presidents' letters in this book.
They come and go in all
different kinds of chapters.
Thomas Jefferson's letters to
his children and grandchildren,
not letters that would
have made them rush
to open the envelopes
every time they saw one.
My for all of his genius,
he could be difficult.
He really tries to run
their lives impart wisdom.
There's not exactly a light
touch to the Jefferson letters
but they're fascinating for
their intellectual content.
Lincoln, for all that
we know about Lincoln,
we only have about 400
of Lincoln's letters.
They're masterly but they're
very different from the Lincoln
that we know of as a man.
They're very short.
The greatest storyteller ever
to occupy the White House.
Lincoln always had time
for an illustrative story,
the way Ronald Reagan always
like to stop the action.
And let me -- it reminds
me of a story.
Lincoln in his letters has
no time for storytelling.
They're short, they're urgent
and Lincoln made during the
civil war an immediate adaptation
to the telegram.
He communicated with him
battlefield generals by telegram
and was often extremely terse
and extremely pointed with them.
He gets a letter from General
McClellan who's so slow
and never getting anything done
and he just asks him would
you mind telling me what it is
that your horses have
done to become so fatigued
because you never seem
to move out of camp.
Franklin Roosevelt, a master
of the short affectionate note
does not write long letters
but writes these cards that were --
I mean Winston Churchill said
meeting Franklin Roosevelt it was
like your first glass of champagne
and that's what Roosevelt's notes
were like, short, pick-me-ups,
often encouraging, very
light, a kind of tonic.
Teddy Roosevelt, an advice
giver, wrote many, many --
he's the champion of
presidential letter writers,
wrote 150,000 of them and wrote
many of them to his children
that were full of advice about
how to live the strenuous life.
They're often very tender, full
of nicknames, silliness, nonsense,
and they're always
written on the fly
because he's always doing
something very strenuous.
And Roosevelt to one of his children
writes my favorite postscript
of all time.
After writing this very
affectionate letter to his child,
"P.S. I have just killed a bear."
If I were ask you to wind up here.
If I were to ask you what president
you thought was the champion love
letter writer of all time in the
White House, who would answer?
Or let me put the question
differently,
who would you say would be least
likely with the possible exception
of Richard Nixon because
that's the kind of gimme, like,
take Nixon off the table.
And he wrote actually
very charming letters
to Pat Nixon when he courted her.
But who might be just
about the least likely?
[ Shouts from audience ]
>>Thomas Mallon: Taft,
I'm that's, you know,
I can't think of a
better answer than that.
Maybe just on physical grounds but
my answer would've been at least
when I was writing this, Woodrow
Wilson, so pinched, so professorial,
you know, with the severe little
glasses looking like he just come
from the Princeton Lecture Hall, the
most scholarly of our presidents.
Well, in fact, Wilson arrived
at the White House married
to his first wife, Ellen who
died of Bright's disease in 1914,
the second year that he was there.
He went into a tremendous depression
afterwards, which his relatives
and friends tried to bring
him out of by introducing him
to a woman named Edith Galt who
was a very plump, lively widow.
She was married to the man
who ran Galt's Jewelry Store,
which was in Washington
for nearly 200 years.
And they introduced the two
of them hoping it would divert
Wilson from his troubles.
Well, they got more
than they bargained for.
This famously professorial
figure was mad
for her from the first moment.
They met and they begin
sending letters across town.
She only lives blocks away but they
begin sending letters sometimes two,
three times a day to each other.
And though I would read you
just a couple of paragraphs.
This is the way the book kind
of carries this combination
of commentary and quotation.
Edith Galt was a less
cerebral companion
than Ellen, his first wife had been.
In one decollate portrait, this
juicy corporeal presence looks
like Madame X as seen
through the eyes of Botero.
And it not hard to
imagine how Wilson
who once said he was carrying a
volcano inside felt ready to blow.
"If I ever again have to with
you for an hour and half",
he writes her on June 5th,
"with only two stolen glances
to express my all but irresistible
desire to take you in my arms
and smother you with kisses, I
am sure I shall crack an artery."
Two weeks later while Edith has tea
at the White House with Helen Bones,
his niece who was one of the
people who fixed him up with Edith,
Wilson hides behind some lace
curtains in the Green Room.
Taft could not have done that.
He would not have fit behind them.
And he writes to her afterwards
that he quote, "Feasted his eyes
on the loveliest person in the world
with oh, so such a longing to go
to her and take her in my arms
and cover her with kisses."
He more than once talks about
his competing personalities,
"The boy that is in me who
has found a perfect playmate.
The lover in me who has found love
like his own and the
man of affairs."
And in a summer of war fevers,
this is 1915, he turns Edith's love
for him into her patriotic duty.
"I am absolutely dependent on
intimate love for the right
and free, and most
effective use of my powers.
Consider what it costs my
work to do without it."
I would say that is a unique
of epistolary blackmail.
You have to do this
for your country.
The White House usher in those
days had the very strange name
of Ike Hoover.
It almost sounds as if it
was an Republican plant
in the Wilson White
House with these names
of future Republican presidents.
And Lincoln -- Wilson would send
him down to the old post office,
what's down on Pennsylvania Avenue,
where I used to work
when I was at the NEH.
He would send him down in the
evening to see if the 9:30 mail
from New York had come in when
Edith was traveling and to see
if it had brought anything from her.
He eventually suffered from writer's
cramp because he was writing
so many handwritten
letters and began
to type his love letters
on a Hammond portable.
But these letters, I think, they
give a glimpse of a president
that we could not get any other way.
And I'll just end with one
letter that he writes to her
on a Saturday night
in August of 1915
where he provides an unforgettable
glimpse of his presidential self.
"I got back to the house before the
band concert on the south lawn was
over and heard I fancied the
greater part of the program
as I sat writing at my desk.
At the end when they played
the Star Spangled Banner,
I stood up all alone",
in his office.
"I stood up all alone here
by my table at attention
and had unutterable thoughts
about my custody of the traditions
and the present honor
of that banner.
I could hardly hold the tears
back and then the loneliness."
And I don't think this is
a glimpse you would get
of Woodrow Wilson in any other way.
I don't think you would get
in any other form but a letter
and I don't think you would
get it in any other --
to any other recipient other
than this woman he was completely
mad for and unguarded with.
Once they married, which
they did, in the White House,
the letter stopped which is
the usual kind of ironic thing
about any collection of love letters
that ends a successful courtship,
there's no need for them anymore.
The two are together and so
they cease writing letters
but together they must have been
thinking of those letters on the day
in 1918 when the two of
them together cut the ribbon
and inaugurated the
first airmail service
of the United States Post Office,
a boon to lovers everywhere
for many decades.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Thomas Mallon: If
there's time for a question
or two I'd be happy to take one.
There are microphones there.
Two fast questions the
pavilion man tells me.
Anybody? This gentleman.
>>Have you seen any of
Obama's love letters?
>>No, I haven't but I would
not pass up the opportunity.
You know one of the
things that is interesting
and I think a little bit sad
now is we have a President
in the White House who is
a very graceful writer.
He is a book writer man
who can write his own
books when he wants to.
But I don't think we
will know him from --
we won't know his presidency
from the letters he writes,
the personal letters and so forth.
Since Richard Nixon, there's been
what commentators like to call a
"chilling effect" on
presidential correspondence,
just as we will never have tapes
made again in the Oval Office.
Presidents, I think, are much
more reserved about putting things
on paper than they used to be.
When Hillary Clinton was the First
Lady, she said quite seriously
that she would like to be keeping a
diary of her time in the White House
but she knew that eventually
it would wind being subpoenaed
for something so she didn't.
And I think we are
the poorer for that.
I mean it'll be -- we'll know
the President through some
of his writings but
not through the kind
of personal writings
that Wilson had.
And this last one, yes.
>>Thank you.
I was just wondering whether
you have any point of view
about all the letters that were
destroyed by families and --
like I think of Jane
Austen's letters that were --
a lot of them burned by her sister.
How do you account for
the letters that survive
and what do you think separates
these different circumstances?
>>Thomas Mallon: Well,
it's, you know,
it's a very interesting question.
It's very difficult for somebody
who wants to get rid of a group
of letters because they are
going to recall some sad,
painful, private situation.
It's very difficult to say to that
person, no, you have an obligation
to literary history, you have
an obligation to biographers
who may be coming after you.
I mean many writers have done this.
Dickens famously had his
bonfire on Gads Hill when he got,
you know, rid of many things.
I do thinks it's mostly a
question for the archivist
at the Library of Congress.
The most urgent question at
the moment is how are we going
to save those letters
and communications and by
that I really mean, e-mail from
writers, famous people, so forth
and make them available
to scholars and writers
and just ordinary readers the
way we've had letters available
to us for so long.
That is still so much influx now and
it's not really a settled question.
So I think that's a real
challenge for the librarians
when they're not putting on
the festival to contend with.
Okay. Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us a LOC.gov.